[Music]
it's time for our former vice president
uh to address him this week in biden
wait if you have a problem figuring out
whether you're for me or trump and you
ain't black
um
in a weekend interview vladimir putin
laughed at the suggestion that you had
called him a killer is that still your
belief sir that he is a killer and i'll
continue the trend if you don't mind
asking a second question do you
believe if he does agree to cooperate
then what kind of a challenge do you
find yourself in how would you ever
trust him and if ronald reagan said
trust but verify what do you say to
vladimir putin
answer the first question
i'm laughing too
they actually uh
well look i mean he has made clear that
uh
uh
yeah the laughing was just actually his
uh remaining blood clots escaping yeah
yeah yeah putin was an idiot maybe it
will clear him
still a big blue spot
wow that is we're all gonna die
can you imagine being putin looking at
that like oh my gosh it's going to be a
cakewalk did you hear what bain said
about you no yeah because he didn't yeah
nothing 10 seconds
i will use my judo black belt to fold
his clothes with him inside them he just
he just saw the light
he just
look at her he had a choice to make he
just saw the light only he saw uh peter
going
yeah
stay stay back stay back
no i think we have a spot down there
before this all blew up though um no pun
intended there biden made some
predictions about the crisis and uh
let's see how they aged
is the taliban takeover of afghanistan
now inevitable no
it is not your own intelligence
community has assessed that the afghan
government will likely collapse that is
not true
is it can you please clarify what they
have told you about whether that will
happen or not that is not true
they did not heard you the first time
did not respect the closure
uh we're back inside uh we're just
showing you again our viewers who are
following this uh just showing you again
those pictures from earlier of taliban
fighters behind the desk of the
president
any parallels between this withdrawal
and what happened in vietnam with some
people feeling whatsoever zero what you
had is you had entire brigades breaking
through the gates of our embassy
six if i'm not mistaken
the taliban is not the south of the
north vietnamese army
they're not they're not remotely
comparable in terms of capability
there's going to be no circumstance
where you see people being lifted off
the roof of a
embassy in the of the united states from
afghanistan see
so charlotte one assumes that that is
the evacuation process ongoing that what
we're looking at in terms of helicopters
yeah what you're looking at we've just
had
uh two more helicopters take off from
the us embassy
we were clear-eyed about the risk
we planned for every contingency but
i always promise the american people
that i will be straight with you
the truth is
this did unfold more quickly than we had
anticipated oh my gosh wow look next
time
next time
next time next time we'll be prepared
when you were going to say that this
will not be like saigon you better make
damn sure that helicopters are not
currently flying into rescue and i know
that statement was made a little bit
before
but they could have gone back and said
well maybe maybe it'll be a little like
psychiatrists
will be involved you know it's like just
a bad look can you imagine working for
him on his pr team right now you're just
like everything he says right now just
can can we come up kamala please help
here's an ice cream cone shut up please
i know
at the g7 summit this weekend world
leaders gathered to hash out global
issues and they kicked it off with some
hardy elbow bumps
stop it oh my goodness of course john
like a chia pet stop oh look at that
enough
white people with no rhythm whatsoever
yeah quarter black how unacceptable is
their whiteness
it amazes me like you think also if you
look at the the panel of them all
standing there where's the black
representation no there's no there's
none if there was one he'd be like i'm
not doing that elbow thing that's stupid
they should just cut to yeah just like
tiny zeus lister
[Music]
give me your chain listen is a fist bump
so hard really yeah come on why it's in
this
yeah yeah you're unmasked but you're
like
so lame oh no we didn't show the
canadian prime minister he was masked
and elbow bumping oh yes was he really
and also
blackface again which pretending he's
representing an actual country if if
trudeau is fist bumping in in blackface
he's at least trying
but
he didn't go that far this country just
reached the population of metro la yeah
there you go i bet if they were miked
you could hear them all just go what's
up brother
i need to say with a little more soul
you've been hanging out with these guys
yeah brother you want to go down to the
tennis club homie banana plate i like
polo
you like lacrosse brother
we represent we need oracle
yeah
i'm just saying we i think uh swipes can
admit when we're uh not good at stuff
severely uncool yeah so fairly uncool
which is fine as long as you own it yeah
you gotta accept it that's why i don't
go up to people like hey
and dave
such elbows
you know that you know what that's
called it's this is called the weenus is
it called the weninus you can look this
up is it touching
that in like kindergarten it looks like
the weanest listen i don't want to touch
anybody else's weenus okay uh i'm just
not an elbow bump guy
because my uncle never was like you need
to have a firm wiener shake
that's going to get you a job
demand respect not any kind of job you
want dave no
it's a bad career yeah i heard him wrong
[Laughter]
but the real highlights this week was uh
former vice president joe biden's gaffes
to welcome uh those who have just joined
us bringing some pretty spectacular
weather uh with them prime minister
uh president
president
in just a minute
gonna get in trouble with staff i don't
do this the right way jennifer jacob
bloomberg
thank you sir
the european allies
i'm gonna get in trouble with my pr my
staff yeah go ahead but i pretend that
you didn't answer your time you've kept
in place some trump-era steel and
aluminum sanctions
and i wanted to ask you when you're
having these conversations with european
allies who are very concerned about
these sanctions how do you justify that
and what are your plans 120 days give me
a break
need time
covert as
i know you all know but a lot of people
may not know what covert is what was 120
days ago the last time you get his pants
i need more time
i i gotta i ate a lot of total
total
i love how like 30 seconds before he
mentions he welcomes the president of
south africa he's like well
hold on borah south africa yeah i got
you covered man he's like and then he
just puts his hand out like a senile old
man oh oh oh please don't say anything
else um what do i say yes as i just said
as i said earlier i look how he thinks
they're laughing with him i know no and
they're not he is so desperate to be one
of the cool kids he like just absolutely
wants to be accepted amongst that group
and will do anything and say anything to
get it
so one thing i wanted to be clear a lot
of people were saying hey i think you
might be unfair uh yesterday with with
biden saying
sticking like the blue angels when all
of them went straight into the earth
the e r n word at a munich conference
yeah and uh here's the thing susan would
you youtube don't take don't take my
word for it right lavar burton and then
it's like he points to a bunch of he's
like i'm not qualified here's a
six-year-old um i like the pop-up book
it's a book
aren't you the host shouldn't i take
your word for it lavar i don't know go
put on your stupid glasses so don't take
my word for it youtube captioning we did
not do this the auto captioning confirms
repeatedly repeatedly and i was
surprised that the captioning actually
included the entire spelling of the
n-word really uh yeah here let's roll
the clip this is youtube captioning on
bind speech from our show yesterday i'm
either here i'm eager to hear
niggered here next
yeah hold on a second i know what you're
gonna not a word whisker but it's a bad
whisker
here's we it's just a case for those who
missed it niggered here next over here
oh that's a word
there you have it there you have it
so youtube thank you for saving us from
a lawsuit from you by being you
okay so a few things that biden got
wrong here when he was talking at his
press conference uh outdoors by the way
yes
i also love how he put on his sunglasses
like three times to leave and then came
back
i won't get fooled again huh
i got four questions okay thanks guess
who it's the who
joe the hell's the difference it's a
huge difference
two different things
so biden began by saying out loud that
he was given a list of reporters to call
on he said this here you go okay i'll
take your questions and as usual folks
they gave me a list
of the people i'm going to use on so uh
jonathan associated press
okay wow so comparing this again we're
talking about quiet parts
that's all he does as a position of
strength
now here's the issue you would have with
donald trump if donald trump had been
given a list of reporters to call on and
uh
they asked him about it you would say no
no it's my list
yeah
i made it because he understands that
you don't want to look like a puppet
former vice president joe biden uh also
confused putin with president trump uh i
caught part of president's uh trump
putin's uh
press conference and he talked about the
need for us to be able to have some kind
of modus operandi where he dealt with
making sure the arctic was in fact
a free zone um i mean it makes sense
because he checks under his bed for both
he's so boring they put him on c-span
three
i didn't even know there was a c-span
what's c-span two uh buffalo wildlings
cornhole championship
it's the red bull bmx off a cliff event
how about joe biden that'd be
interesting he thinks that whatever
putin says is is gospel yeah like do you
not understand he's like yeah it's gonna
totally be a free zone they got a lot of
warships up there and they're taking our
land but don't worry he probably said
yeah there's got to be a free zone yeah
yeah
and i think now they're just so
complacent uh they are so comfortable
with the media carrying their water that
joe biden doesn't realize that even the
media is going to have to backtrack now
and address the lie that he spouts on
january 6th
and uh saying that the rioters killed an
officer which we know is not true when
president putin was questioned today
about human rights he said the reason
why he's cracking down on opposition
leaders um is because he doesn't want
something like january 6 to happen in
russia and he also said he doesn't want
to see groups formed like black lives
matter what's your response to that
please
my response is kind of what i
communicated but i think that's a
that's a ridiculous comparison
it's one thing for
literally criminals
to break through
cordon
go into the capitol kill a police
officer didn't have to be held
unaccountable you are faking this for
people objecting and marching on a
capital one saying you are not allowing
me to speak freely you are not allowing
me to do a b c or d
and so they're very different criteria
okay um this is something
if if you if people were to want if the
if the left were to want a civil war
which god forbid ever happens in this
country this is how you do it
this is how you do it what you do is
tell americans that what they are seeing
what they are experiencing at least two
billion dollars in damages it's been a
year since they've uh they've upped the
number since they've updated it probably
four billion when we're talking about
the black lives matter right cities
burning dozens of deaths hundreds of
officer casualties city halls
walgreens police precincts being burned
right right in front of their eyes
people being shot in autonomous zones
that were erected in a complete state of
lawlessness and you say all they were
doing was saying that they weren't
allowed to speak as opposed to january 6
and then you lie and say where someone
killed an officer if you want this is
sort of
exactly if you look at the playbook of
people who want to create civil unrest
division within their country they used
to accuse donald trump of this yeah what
you do is tell people that exactly what
they're seeing and experiencing isn't so
by the way we have um exclusive i don't
know exclusive video of joe biden
practicing for his speech and by the way
none this is not a dub none of this is
fake
this is real
these white supremacists
nazi sympathizers
carrying nazi [ __ ] flags
juicy knees
jews and evidently
this is uh the first moment that i just
i can't even decipher so we'll try and
analyze it after this uh just as i do on
cnn because we are professionals
but uh
there's you know there to be you know
beginning uh
this effort uh for 2021 is uh i think
we've learned a few lessons from last
year as well
there's help as we they're
you know being there to help clear roads
rebuild
main streets
and so that the families can get back to
their lives
that's what fema does every single day
someone help him ah oh i thought he was
getting better
did anyone here understand what he was
trying to say no no
no one i'm still trying to figure it out
i'm look and i'm not sometimes i've said
this when you're watching debates like
oh he meant to say this he misspoke
your guess is as good as mine
is that the war room he's in i have no
idea he's talking gosh can you imagine
him in the war room
now it's sad that i'm saying that this
is uh let me set up this clip biden
former vice president joe biden just had
yet another
uh poor kids are just as smart as white
kids moments really yeah this this was
just yesterday
you're former vice president the data
shows
young black entrepreneurs are just as
capable of succeeding given the chance
as white
entrepreneurs are
but they don't have lawyers they don't
have this surprises you they don't have
accountants
but they have great ideas
does anyone doubt this whole nation be
better off bro from the investments
those people nick and i promise you
that's why i set up this
national small business administration
that's much broader because they're
going to get those loans imagine if that
guy was your public defendant uh
just yes i'm going to jar he's your
divorce attorney she's gonna get
everything they're giving you death for
parking tickets yeah
he also just claimed to set up the small
business association which was around
before he was born which by the way
that's why i did it
he said
business
[Laughter]
i'm getting better
um and by the way this is this is not a
new sentiment we've talked about this
it's not even the racism of soft
expectations it's just racism joe biden
thinks that black people are less
capable and so that's why he has to like
a daily affirmation black people are
just as capable as white people black
people just keep looking at white people
as capable as white people he does it's
like in his meditation app because this
is him uh i believe back in yeah it's
2019 so not that long ago we have this
notion that somehow if you're poor you
cannot do it
poor kids are just as bright and just as
tall as white kids
oh
bro no
i love that he's dressed like judge
smails
i love that that's the most honest
moment we get out of him and by the way
this isn't so this isn't all the he this
is this is a long this week in biden
um it's really more of a a fortnight
how long is a fortnight two weeks four
nights two weeks okay
because that's how they actually kept
time when he was yeah
yeah yeah we do it through lines on the
wall with a carving tool
someone can someone sharpen my carving
tool i'm the president for god's sake uh
then he said something else really uh
stupid uh but still funny according the
intelligence community
terrorism from white supremacy is the
most lethal threat to the homeland today
not isis
not al-qaeda
white supremacists
yeah
huh stop it set it to code orange
more of a tope he doesn't say words like
two and the anymore no he doesn't notice
that he's like it's the most
threatening yeah yeah jump right over it
i wipe it
threat you white ah did i say more yeah
you actually need to say a lot more
because we don't understand anything
you're saying from a vice president
them connection words
you push
up we do
you know the you know the thing he's
becoming unfrozen caveman lawyer
it's former vice president biodome
your world frightens and confuses
um
i should have never played that board
game ju jews manji did the jews
manchester united
the hebrews eating snacks
um and here's something that he actually
said and this is this is uh absolutely i
know you're gonna think this is kind of
it's not really a sketch we just made
sure to emphasize this is actually
something he said in chronological order
you make sense of it i challenge you
find today
when you turn on the stations
sit on one station for two hours
and i don't know how many commercials
you'll see
yes say eight to five
two to three out of five
mixed-race couples that's not by
accident they're selling soap man
not a joke because they want to sell
what they have
we have hope i'm right now damn right
wow all of that made no sense except
he's racist would you would you like to
have some get some soap yeah okay no do
you totally put it put it away we don't
knock the animal stuff on them
on this show no not on this show no no
okay so this is by just so you know it
makes about as much sense as tenant i'm
pretty tired dave is pretty tired even
then this still doesn't make sense it's
biden talking about
really a subject where he has a certain
level of expertise amtrak
if you think about it
when
we were when i was vice president with
barack he allowed me to put together a
budget for amtrak
and it had money for high-speed rail at
200 miles an hour
from
from uh
char excuse me from charlotte he's doing
math now one
another line going from in florida
down to tampa
another line if we had moved go we'd
have that tunnel fixed in new york now
the money was there to get it done
what the
what are we doing well former vice
president joe biden the little engine
that couldn't i like it i don't care
about the
wow that video clip was something else
isn't that right dave
i enjoyed it thoroughly yeah it was uh
clipped from the live show every monday
through thursday at 10 a.m eastern
that's the best way you can just tune in
watch and you know comment with us live
if you want to support this content
because
no one else is going to crowdershop.com
hit the like
share more importantly
buy a shirt
because there are some people
who will be lucky to have shirts
in china they're starving